alors
il ya certains pays qui qui sont au
rendez vous le g7 globalement vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le président et
tous rendez vous avec les annonces de
l'union européenne - 55% au moins de
réductions d'émissions d'ici 2030 par
rapport à 1990 qui est un relèvement
considérable de notre ambition initiale
qui était à -40%
vous avez rappelé les engagements des
états unis du canada du japon tous tous
les pays du g7 sont en ordre de bataille
si je puis dire
alors au delà du g7 est évidemment g20
qui concentre toutes les attentions sur
le volet atténuation qu'est ce que le
g20 constituent 80% des émissions
mondiales hélas le paysage est beaucoup
plus contrastée nous avons des pays qui
ont certes rendu leur copie avec de
nouvelles contributions nationales mais
dont on peut déplorer le manque
d'ambition en réalité ne sont pas plus
ambitieuse que celle qu'elle avait
soumises cinq ans auparavant et je peux
les citer il s'agit il s'agit de pays
tels que la russie telles que le brésil
tels que l'indonésie tels que
l'australie pays de l' ocde
tels que le mexique également
il ya des pays qui n'ont toujours pas
remis de contribution bien qu'il se soit
engagé lors de la ministérielle climat
du g20 en juillet dernier à remettre
comme l'ensemble des pays du g20 à
remettre des contributions déterminées
au niveau national ambitieuse verbatim
et ces pays c'est la chine c'est la
turquie c'est l'arabie saoudite
c'est l'inde donc nous avons encore des
acteurs majeurs du débat qui n'ont pas
remis leurs contributions déterminées au
niveau national rousset ou nouvelles
alors dans ce paysage un peu lugubre que
je vous livre il ya quand même des
bonnes nouvelles récentes et qui me
donne des raisons d'espérer pour une
nouvelle dynamique lors deux à la fois
du g20 qui aura lieu les 30 et 31
octobre et lors de la cop elle même qui
s'ouvrira le jour du g20 d'avoir la
turquie a annoncé
la surprise générale il faut bien le
dire
par la voix de son président arnaud
gagnent une ratification de l'accord de
paris ratification qui s'est traduite
dans les fêtes à peine une semaine plus
tard le parlement étant particulièrement
efficace en turquie sur ce point en tout
cas
nous avons la chine qui a fait une
annonce très significative tout
récemment au delà de celle qu'elle avait
qu'elle avait fait des annonces qu'elle
avait fait ces derniers mois sur sur le
pic des émissions avant 2030 sur la
neutralité carbone en 2060 la chine a
pris un engagement sectoriel très
significatif qui est la fin des
constructions de centrales à charbon à
l'étranger nous avons aussi des pays
comme l'afrique du sud autres pays du
g20 qui a remis là il ya une dizaine de
jours une contribution déterminée au
niveau national
jugé très ambitieuse qui nous qui la met
sur une trajectoire
conforme aux objectifs de l'accord de
paris les émirats arabes unis pays
pétroliers s'il en est qui annonce une
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 la
corée du sud qui n'a pas encore remis
formellement sa cdn mais qui a déjà
révélé qu'elle haussait l'ambition de
manière significative avec moins 40% de
réduction d'ici 2030 par rapport à 2018
donc vraiment une dynamique
incontestable qui se fait sentir
al'approche de la coop sous l'effet
conjugué d'une pression diplomatique
très forte de la part de l'ensemble des
partenaires de au sein du g20
[Musique]